hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and I've got a bunch of
cast iron cookware here that needs
repair needs restoration and need some
seasoning and we're gonna walk you
through how to do just that
[Music]
welcome to the show and let me introduce
you to the cast iron and this is my
modern-day Lodge Dutch oven and it is
grimy and full of old oil and soot and
ash and needs to be cleaned badly but
other than it's doing pretty good
so I'm gonna use this to demonstrate how
to clean cast iron this is another piece
of modern Lodge cookware it's a griddle
and it's been used and abused to the
seasonings all gone and it's covered in
rust and it has a lot of damage but no
pitting and nothing too serious I'm
gonna use this to demonstrate knocking
off some loose rust and REE seasoning
this skillet was made by lodge a few
years ago and it has been used and
abused it's doing okay on the inside
just need some reasoning but on the back
it's got some pretty heavy-duty rust
damage so I'm gonna remove the rust and
then re season the whole thing this is
an unmarked Wagner skillet it's a ten
and a half inch skillet from probably
around the 1950s and it is in some bad
shape it is covered completely and rust
with absolutely no seasoning I'm able to
tell it's a Wagner because of the font
and the lettering it says ten and a half
inch skillet and then it has the size
number or on it and it's got the size on
the top of the handle additionally I can
tell it's post 1950s because it's got a
smooth bottom but it doesn't say made in
the USA on it this is a very old pot
it's got a gate mark which is a mark
left over from the manufacturing process
which puts it probably in the 1800's
sometime and it is in really rough shape
it has got lots of heavy pitting heavy
rust and the inside of it it has an
enamel lining that's very damaged and it
has about 1/8 inch deep pits all
throughout the bottom so this thing is
in serious trouble I really don't know
if I can save this one but we're gonna
try alright guys it's time to get the
rust off this cast iron and to do that
I'm gonna use three different methods
the first method I'm going to use is
electrolysis the second method is a
vinegar bath and thirdly I'm going to
use coca-cola this is my first time
using the coca-cola method so I'm going
to get a chance to compare it
against the vinegar method to make it
electrolysis baths all you need is a
plastic bin full of water and then
you're gonna want to add a fair amount
of baking soda in this amount of water
I'm putting about an eighth of a cup of
baking soda mix it up really good and
then get yourself a piece of metal you
don't mind ruining in this example I've
got a piece of old rebar then I'm gonna
take my old pot and I'm gonna sink it
down in here and I've got it hanging
suspended in the water I don't want it
resting on the bottom and I've got it
tied with a piece of metal coat hanger
in this example now what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna hook up a battery charger to
this and I'm gonna put the positive on
the sacrificial anode that you want to
ruin and I'm gonna put the negative on
the pot that I want the rust to come off
of the more amps you run through this
the more aggressively it's going to to
work you can tell things are starting to
work when you'll see bubbles and fizzing
the closer you place the sacrificial
anode to the base metal the stronger the
reaction and so you can effectuate which
part you want to focus on based on where
you put the anode put the anode here
this parts gonna clean the fastest now
for this skillet I'm going to use
vinegar to get the rust off I'm just
gonna put it in this plastic pin here
and I've got a gallon of white distilled
vinegar that's five percent acidity so
was three dollars at the grocery store
and we're just gonna pour it on alright
we're gonna let that soak for about an
hour then we're gonna scrub it and soak
it again and scrub it and soak it until
it's clean next we're gonna clean these
two pieces of cast iron using original
coca-cola I've never done this before so
I'm just gonna kind of do it like I
would vinegar and see how it comes out
[Music]
of these three methods hands-down my
favorite for this type of work is the
vinegar bath the electrolysis works but
it's really fidgety you have all this
stuff you need to set up you know this
charger and you need to constantly move
the anode around to get it evenly across
to all the surfaces the vinegar you just
dump it in a bucket of vinegar and it
seems to work fine the coca-cola works
but not as well as the vinegar and it's
more expensive there's a lot of products
and chemicals out on the market they'll
get rid of rust really well and even
better than vinegar however I don't know
if I want to be putting those chemicals
on my cookware and letting it soak for
hours at a time the vinegar the
coca-cola the electrolysis all it does
is loosen the rust it doesn't actually
get it off you still have to use some
elbow grease to do that you can use a
scouring pad at or boy a wire brush a
drill an angle grinder whatever helps
you can use it I got this little wire
adapter at the end of a drill I'm going
to use it to try to get the remainder of
this rust off and if I can't do it I'll
put it back in the vinegar and soak it
some more
[Music]
well you can see what a difference
that's already making getting down to
bare cast-iron
[Music]
all right well the cast-iron skillets
been sitting in the vinegar for another
hour and we're gonna see if the more
stubborn spots have loosened up
[Music]
let's rinse it off in some vinegar and
make sure we got everything that's ten
and a half inch skillet is looking
really good just a few places to touch
up and it'll be done
so rinse it off in the vinegar and as
you can see it's just all nice and shiny
so we are all ready to season this thing
you can see here some of the black spots
where the electrolysis has already
started to work rust is really coming
off right there now restoring this pot
is going to be a special kind of
challenge it's got this broken enamel
lining on the inside and I cannot fix it
there's really nothing I could do about
that so the best thing to do is try to
remove the enamel lining probably the
best way to get rid of the enamel lining
would be a using glass beads in a
sandblaster I do not have that equipment
so instead I'm going to use this this
stripper here
on a power drill and hopefully I can
take off the enamel this doesn't work
I'm gonna upgrade to an angle grinder
and see how that does I'm going to be
doing this forever at this speed I'm
going to try out the angle grinder and
see how well that handles
[Music]
well guys I did something stupid hey it
was grinding and grinding and grinding
away at this enamel and there's an hour
into it and you can see how little
progress I've made
so I thought maybe I could speed this up
if I just gently tap it with a ball-peen
hammer I can just chip away the enamel
and break it off and that would speed up
the process and I was being extremely
gentle and look at this right there just
busted a hole right in the caster and it
cracked all over this pot is from the
1800s and I just broke it learn from my
mistakes first off don't try to buy
antique pots with damaged enamel linings
they are a pain in the butt second of
all don't try to knock the enamel off
with a hammer this is the one that was
soaking in the coca-cola let's get the
rust off here there's some serious rust
on it
this one was really easy only took one
soak in the coca-cola and five minutes
or so with the English minor and the
brush to get it all completely done it
wasn't too bad
well this griddle is pretty well off so
I'm really expecting to do everything
quite quickly with just the electric
drill
[Music]
[Music]
well that looks pretty good got the rust
off the griddle very easily and now one
thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna smooth
the surface a little bit now this is a
modern-day Lodge cast-iron griddle Lodge
deliberately makes their surfaces
slightly textured so that it can pre
season them that they can and season
them quickly and cheaply at the factory
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take this little thing right here and
I'm gonna go and hit the surface and
just take some of that texture off and
that will smooth it out
[Music]
well this is a whole lot smoother and
it's still a few pits in here and
grooves so there's places for the oil to
to bake on in but he'll take fewer
layers of seasoning for this to become
really excellent nonstick once you
remove all the rust the exposed iron is
really susceptible to rusting and
corrosion and you can happen in a matter
of hours so ideally you want to season
your cast iron immediately after
removing the rust that's not realistic
for me today I ran out of time and it's
gonna be a couple days before I pick
this project up again so I'm gonna leave
all this cast iron sitting in this
vinegar submerged and I'll pick it up
again in a couple days and it'll have no
corrosion on it look at that just a
couple days ago it was solid rust
now it's bare cast iron now we need to
clean off the caster and get all that
dirt and grime and metal shavings off
the cast iron now we're gonna do this
using soap and water
now I know some of you out there
thinking oh no you never never use soap
and water to clean cast iron that's not
true you don't use soap and water to
clean seasoned cast iron so at this
point we want to get as clean as
possible soap is the appropriate thing
to do once it's seasoned don't use soap
and you want to get the water as hot as
possible here if you want to know if you
did a good job take a white paper towel
hang it down the towel comes back
relatively clean looking you did a good
job and the towel comes back black you
know you still have some scrubbing to do
once you've got it nice and clean towel
dry the cast iron and put it in the of
it we're just gonna put it in the oven
long enough to make sure it's bone-dry
[Music]
gotta admit that's impressive
transformation that thing looks good if
you have a piece of cast iron that's
only lightly rusted you can get rid of
the rust simply with soap water and a
bit of elbow grease all the electric
drills and angle grinders and vinegar
isn't necessary for things that just got
a little bit a fairly new rust off
[Music]
alright so I've got the cast iron clean
I've got it scrubbed washed bone-dry and
a little bit warm now it's time to apply
the oil to begin seasoning it now I'm
going to use organic flaxseed oil with
no preservatives in it this is just some
of the best stuff you can use to
seasoned cast iron but you can also use
vegetable shortening that you've melted
down you can use canola oil some people
use coconut oil there's a lot of
different things you can use for
seasoning one of the most popular ways
to season cast iron is to take
shortening and wipe it onto a hot piece
of cast iron it melts right in and after
you've covered every square inch of it
with shortening then you take a clean
towel and you wipe off all the excess
put the cast iron in an oven at 400
degrees for about an hour and then
repeat the process two to four times to
build up a layer of seasoning now this
will get the cast iron darker than
flaxseed oil but I prefer flaxseed oil
because it's stronger so let me show you
how to season it with flaxseed oil coat
the warm cast iron in flaxseed oil just
like you would shortening and wipe off
the excess with a clean towel now we're
gonna put it upside down so the oil can
drip off alright we're gonna bake it in
there for one hour at 400 degrees
Fahrenheit
no matter what type of oil you're using
to season your castor and make sure you
don't put too much on it after you apply
the oil wipe off the excess with the dry
clean towel
if you flirt with the oil cast iron in
the oven it puts off a fair amount of
smoke especially you need to do three
items at once so got the fan blow and
smoke out and I've got the fan hood
going full-throttle it was still a
little smoking here but after about 15
minutes it cleared up pretty good so
heads up don't do it when your wife's at
home
so you notice how the seasoning on this
old skillet is kind of splotchy but the
modern-day large skillet it's not that's
because of how these skillets are
designed modern skillets are kind of
bumpy so that they can be pre seasoned
very quickly at the factory it takes a
lot less time and energy to preseason a
slightly bumpy surface the old skillets
are smooth
time for layer number two but again
we're doing it for 400 degrees for one
hour
[Music]
so there we go we've got two layers it's
looking a little darker so there's the
skillet is only the second layer and it
should be very smooth to the touch it
shouldn't be sticky at all if your pan
is sticky that means you haven't cooked
it long enough or you've added too much
oil or both here's the the lodge pan you
can see it's coming along very nice you
can see what the griddle looks like
after three layers of seasoning well
it's hard it's not sticky at all it
doesn't have a greasy feel to it so you
can see what the skillet looks like
after three layers
pretty darn good but still it's more
Brown than black so you can see the
modern large skillet this is looking
really dark it grabs that seasoning
better than the smoother older skillets
but it's bumpier it's not quite as
smooth so here I am on my last layer of
seasoning and the pots and pans skillets
aren't quite black yet so I'm putting
them in for a number of hours until they
just turn black and this is just a way
of finishing up the seasoning and making
sure that thick layer of seasoning is
cooked all the way through yeah check
that out I didn't add any more oil to it
but just a little bit more time in the
oven and it turned perfectly shiny black
that is gorgeous all right we're gonna
do a little bit of troubleshooting here
so I'm gonna demonstrate two common
mistakes and then show you how to fix
them the first is doing too many layers
two to four layers is fine six to seven
layers isn't necessarily better
additionally adding more oil on each
layer isn't better so here I am I'm just
slopping the oil on as much as I can get
on here and I'm gonna cook it in for a
total of six layers on all the cast iron
here and I'm gonna show you what it does
and how to identify it and how to fix it
if your layers of seasoning come out
bumpy and uneven this is a sign that
you're using too much oil you're not
wiping off the excess when you turn it
upside down the drips of oil are
hardening you'll see them along the edge
of the skillet especially and they'll
break off and expose cast iron
and cause weaknesses in your seasoning
if you add too many layers of seasoning
you'll start to get this bumpy surface
that is it as nonstick as it should be
you can remove these bumps and blisters
through sandy removing the bumps in your
seasoning doesn't take a lot of effort
so you can sand by hand very easily or
use a random orbital sander use 800 to a
thousand grit sandpaper and just make a
few passes until it's smooth to the
touch alright just rinse it off
scrub it without using any soap
[Music]
now the fun part guys I'm going to show
you how to cook with cast iron alright
we're going to put this on a medium heat
for about five minutes we're gonna let
that pan absorb all that ki that's the
beauty of cast iron is it absorbs a lot
of heat and distributes it very evenly
with no one Catherine fans you are
constantly moving the food around with
cast iron don't do that
stick the meat down and let it sit there
until the surface caramelizing then it
will release and unstick you can move it
yes
caramelized just releases
[Music]
once you sear the outside of the steaks
turn the heat way down to low then we're
gonna slow cook it I'm gonna put some of
this Montreal steak seasoning on there I
like my steaks to be medium-rare but if
you like to cook yours a little bit more
thoroughly one of the nice things about
cast iron is you can take it and just
put it right into the oven
and that helps cook the steaks nice and
even after you've caramelized the
outside and seared in those juices
beautiful steaks beautiful now we're
gonna cook the vegetables little olive
oil just a dash and I'm gonna roll this
asparagus around so it's getting the
beef juice and the olive oil all mixed
up you want all the asparagus coated
sprinkle them with some garlic salt make
sure you don't overcook the asparagus
it should Bend but it should still be
able to snap if it's floppy you've
overdid it
[Music]
all I'm gonna do is just black in the
pepper a little bit and sprinkle a
little bit of salt on them guys there
you go you can see you got a little bit
of black on the pepper you're good to go
you don't want to overdo already got my
dirty cast iron skillet here from lunch
and all I'm gonna do is just wash it in
warm water and scrub it with a scrub
brush don't overthink it and don't use
soap the trickiest part about cleaning a
cast iron skillet is it's hard to see if
there's any gunk or residue stuck to it
because it's a black you know cast iron
let's just use your fingers really quick
make sure you don't feel anything stuck
to it you're good to go and dry it off
really good with the towel all right
they're nice and clean
dried didn't take you long you don't
want to use metal tools like spatulas
and tongs and forks too aggressively
when using cast iron they can scrape off
the seasoning and that's what you see
here these scratch marks from a pair of
metal tongs it's time to clean this pot
you can see here it's got tons of grease
and soot and all sorts of nasty stuff in
there and even this this is old oil I
think I was making some campfire Donuts
and I didn't clean this thing out
heating up the cast iron can make
cleaning it a little bit easier you know
I still want to be able to handle it but
I want to make it pretty hot to the
touch
[Music]
water is good for removing a suit and
burnt up food but if you try to get
grease off often the dry paper towel
does better than the scrub brush and
water
[Music]
there we go it's all cleaned all right
that's how you restore season cook with
and clean cast iron so not the only way
to do it but it's how I do it and
hopefully it'll get you started and you
learn something new well thanks for
watching guys we hope you enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more great
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget it - wait thanks
for watching we hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you'd like to see more
great videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video